a new book takes an unfiltered look at
China's often highly praised with
insular education system Chinese
American journalist Lenore - moved with
her family to Shanghai back in 2010
students there regularly have some of
the top math and reading test scores in
the world and when her three-year-old
son got into a prestigious Shanghai
preschool they were thrilled she wrote a
book about their experience it's called
little soldiers an American boy a
Chinese school in the global race to
achieve Leonora Chu joins us at the
table good morning to you good morning
thanks so much for having me you know
what I was fascinating about the book is
a clearly teacher knows best in all
situations when it comes to education
including correcting the parents you
tell a very interesting story about your
son being forced to eat an egg and then
when you question the teacher could you
share that that's right so my son hated
eggs when he was three I've been working
on getting him to eat them for you know
a year and the first week of school she
puts eggs in his mouth and basically
holds it shut until he swallows and of
course I'm angry I March after school
and I say you know in America we don't
use methods of force we incent our
children to choose and she says does it
work and later she she told me I
shouldn't question her authority in
front of a child so I knew I was in for
more than I bargained for so that's very
different that clearly then an American
education system that's right so so why
does it work in terms of test scores and
what's the end result of what the
Chinese believe in so from this incident
I haven't be a journalist and I had the
skills to sort of look into some of
these questions and from there I
launched this investigation talking to
parents students teachers and I think
that you know force-feeding aside
teacher authority aside there are some
things that we can learn from the system
and one of them is this belief in grit
in the classroom it's there's a term in
Chinese culture called shook who are
eating bitter and we believe that hard
work is connected to achievement in
America the studies show were more
likely to believe in talent when it
comes to academics and that means we're
sort of giving up on some kids because
we think they don't have what it takes
they also seem to focus more on the
group Lenora than the individual student
sure they do and and you know there's
there's negatives and positives to that
my son had asthma and I tried to get an
inhaler cut near the classroom they
couldn't make this dispensation
him and so I had to decide could I take
care of it on my own and you know if you
think about it
without these sort of distractions for
the teacher they're able to focus on
yeah they were saying your son's
individual needs do not Trump what's
happening in this that's right that's
right and clearly it's not for everyone
we're really lucky that our son you know
so did everything you learn cause you to
reassess how you might want to see your
child treated and stimulated in school
yeah absolutely you know so we do things
really well in America in in some areas
and one of them is that we're constantly
asking our kids what they think if you
sit in a US classroom and I spend a good
amount of time visiting classrooms in
the US for comparison the teacher is
always saying what do you think about
what we just talked to self-esteem
matters that's what yeah that's right
and so we're teaching our kids critical
thinking skills in the classroom they go
home and parents asked the same
questions and that is not what the
average Chinese child is getting and so
what we try to do at home is we have
these counter measures for what
he gets at school you also write that
that Chinese parents are also formally
roped into their child's education
whether they like it or not how does the
parental involvement differ so my son's
principal the first day says we don't
pick children we pick parents and she
actually had told a friend of mine that
she needed a quitter job so she could be
fully involved if there's a lot of
pressure for the entire family to be
involved in a child's education
that's a good thing it's good and bad
yes it depends on where you are know you
tell the story with a violin along with
her child to show that that's right he's
very engaged in playing the violin along
with her truck he bought two instruments
one for her one for herself so she could
practice alongside and and you know
that's the Chinese way if you actually
think about it one child the one-child
policy so you have two parents and then
you have four grandparents so you have
six kids all of these expectations
placed on the sponge it's not a good
idea bring a violin and to learn
together I mean as a kid growing up
there was nothing better than having
parents to influence you to throw a ball
with him and throw a football and
participate in sports that's right
that's right there's a term in Chinese
culture Family Education it's really
it's a game that involves everybody but
the bottom line for Raney is
you're glad that he's doing what he's
doing no back to Charlie's we're really
grateful that he has so he has a teacher
knows best classroom and there are some
things he is doing really really love
math the science shows that some
subjects are better taught with a
teacher centered classroom but then he
has us at home and he has an equal seat
at the table with us so I feel like
we're able to give him that sort of
middle ground and I spend the last third
of my book looking at what that might be
for the rest of us how quickly about
what the title of this book came from
sure so there's a there's there's a
military like aspect to the Chinese
students education and it was also the
title of a song that he was taught in
kindergarten little soldiers I set my
eyes on the distance I work hard every
day really interesting Nora - so nice to
meet you thank you very much little
soldiers is on sale today